you
[Music]
okay so let's go ahead and get started
so it's my pleasure to welcome Tudor
David
so tutors been doing his PhD at EPFL
with a specialization in concurrency and
synchronization so if you're at SOS P a
few years ago you might have heard and
talked about thank everything you've
always wanted to know about
synchronization but we're afraid to ask
so if for all these years you've been
afraid to ask about synchronization not
now's your chance and he'll be telling
us about concurrency and specifically
concurrent in structures today thank you
Chris
so hello everyone and thanks for being
here so doing my dissertation I've
mostly worked on multi-core systems and
one of the common themes throughout the
various projects that the work done have
been concurrent data structures and
that's why I'm today I'm mostly going to
be talking about that
so really data structures are one of the
main concerns of computer science it's
why we studied them in our CS 101 course
and today they're everywhere from
multi-core systems whether in your OS
kernel or in knob in memory cache or
storage engine home or so on but they're
also present in distributed systems a
shortage key value store for example may
be nothing more than a partition hash
table for example or more recent data
structures such as blockchain is
essentially a replicated data structure
so really these data structures are
everywhere now while my work has looked
both at multi-core data structures and
at some distributed data structures
today we'll be mostly focusing on data
structures for multi-course so
traditionally what we wanted from the
ideal data structure was for it to be
fast in a sequential environment it's
why we study sequential complexity when
we first start studying computer science
and ideally we would want it to be
simple to design and to reason about and
use and practice now of course today as
our machines have become multi cores or
wish list has scalability on it as well
we want the output that we produce to be
proportional to the amount of resources
that we invest in our
so as I said whether you're thinking
about a phone or a laptop or a server in
some remote data center today your
processor looks something like this
it's a multi-core you cannot think of it
as having a single processing unit and
we're investing the extra transistors
that for now we're still getting into
cramming more and more cores in our
processors please for the next few years
in particularly in a data center you
commonly have multiple such processors
in a single machine so you want to be
able to use or all these Hardware
resources so you want systems that whose
performance is proportional to the
number of cores that you have that you
use for them and that's not that easy
because a very common pattern in
multi-core systems is something like
this where you have a lot of parallel
threads accessing some form of shared
state and they need to coordinate and
synchronize on how they exit this shared
state in order for the outcome to be
correct and more often than not in
especially in scalable system this
shared state is some data structure very
commonly I search their structure and
I'll be back to what this means exactly
in a second and this is true for this is
a pattern that you encounter in a lot of
systems and operating systems storage
engines data stores in memory caches and
so on so the point I'm trying to make
here is that really these concurrent
data structures that are at the core of
these systems are really a critical
component for the overall performance of
scalability of the system of course
there are other aspects that influence
performance of scalability but really
probably the main one is this ok so I've
used the term concurrent search data
structures and I said that they're at
the core of many systems so what are
these well they're defined through their
very simple interface that has methods
to insert remove and search for elements
they generally model the set abstraction
and implementations includes very
commonly known very well-known data
structures such as hash tables a tree
skip lists list and so on these have
been studied extensively
but I claim that there are still a
number of issues with them it's still
not yet clear exactly what is it that
enables a a concurrent search data
structure to be scalable so let's say
you're building your multi-core system
you want it to scale you're at the point
where you're trying to design the data
structure on which the system is based
on it's not really clear how the data
structure should look like such that
you're guaranteed to have scalability in
your final system then concurrency is a
discipline that's very well known for
being bug prone in fact correctness
problems are being found all the time
even in published algorithms in
peer-reviewed conferences in addition
it's very clear that software systems
need to be adapted to the underlying
technologies and as technologies evolve
so do so do software systems and where
for example one technology that will
become widely available in the next
couple of years is non-volatile Ram and
we don't yet know what's the best way of
designing such concurrent data
structures assuming you have persistent
RAM at your disposal so these are some
of the issues that I've tried to tackle
with respect to these data structures ok
so first of all the first question that
I've looked at was what is it exactly
that enables our concurrent search data
structure to be scalable and this is
actually a very difficult question to
answer because well in fact if you start
and design a concurrent data structure
algorithm then you end up with something
that's scalable you can probably end up
with the publication a very good
concurrency conference and that just
shows how difficult this is but the
thing is all these methods are pretty
ad-hoc from the outside they look like
it's magic why exactly does an algorithm
scale and another doesn't so we would
like to have some more a more
disciplined approach to building
scalable data structures of course there
are some techniques that are generic in
a sense in particular there is RCU which
is very well known it is generic in the
sense that it allows you to build all
sorts of data structures starting from
these techniques or concurrent link list
but concurrent tree that's based on RCU
and so on
this is not generic in every sense it's
targeted to some very specific workloads
in particular our Cu is targeted at read
dominated workloads so just to give you
an example here I'm using an RC base
hash table I'm measuring how its
throughput involved as we add more and
more cores that are executing they're
running this hash table and well if we
have a read-only workload everything's
great
we get linear scalability this is what
we want but as soon as we introduce a
non negligible fraction of updates our
scalability decreases significantly so
really our to use generic in the sense
that it allows you to the different data
structures but it is aimed at
predominating workload sure it's read
copy update yeah ok so we would like to
be able to have some more generic way of
building concurrent search data
structures that that are scalable so we
want actually scalability across
different dimensions so in the previous
slide I mentioned that we want
scalability for different kinds of
workloads so we want to get ability for
read-only workloads but we also want
scalability as the workload contain more
and more writes in addition we want
scalability according to different
metrics so we want our algorithms to be
fishing from throughput perspective but
also from an energy consumption
perspective and latency perspective and
also we would like them to be scalable
on different kinds of platforms we would
like them to be scalable on I don't
platforms with flow non-uniformity in
their memory system but also on
platforms with high non-uniform it in
their memory systems and this last
dimension is something that we actually
showed is is very important for
concurrent application in a study of
synchronization that we did before this
work so can we obtain this portable
scalability so the scalability across
these different dimensions
now before I try to provide an answer
for this it's important to understand
what exactly does it mean for an
algorithm to be scalable so if I run for
example a linked list algorithm with 20
concurrent threads and 20 percent
updates in my workload on an Intel
server and I get 10 times more
throughput with 20 threads than I would
with one thread is that good enough is
that scalable implementation can I do
better it's not really clear and what if
I change the data structure what if I
have a hash table instead of a linked
list so to try to to obtain a reasonable
upper bound forward you can obtain in
terms of performance and in terms of
scalability we propose just deploying
the sequential algorithms that you study
in your cs101 course in a concurrent
environment without any synchronization
of course this will result in the sum in
correctness there will be some updates
that will be lost but uh they do provide
a pretty good approximation of what you
can do in terms of throughput and
scalability in a particular situation
using a particular type of data
structure and we call these a
synchronized execution so execution so a
sequential algorithm deployed in a
concurrent environment and just to show
you the fact that they do provide a
reasonable upper bound and this is in
fact useful in practice I've taken here
linked lists and hash table algorithms
and I've deployed them on two kinds of
platforms on an MD server and on an
Intel server so first I'm going to plot
concurrent implementations of different
published algorithms so these are all
correct concurrent implementations and
I'm showing how their stupid evolves as
we increase the number of cores so we
can see that there is clearly a
difference between well for example how
a linked list and a hash table scales
there is also clearly a difference
between how a hash table scales on
different kinds of platforms and then of
course there are differences between the
different concurrent algorithms
themselves but it's not yet clear are
these good enough can we do much better
in any one of these particular
situations and while we do deploy those
they synchronize executions and we see
that these do actually provide us with a
reasonable and realistic upper bound in
all of these scenarios so we could use
this as a guideline for how well we can
do in practice
okay so now having these asynchronous
executions are at our upper bound we can
provide an answer to our previous
question yes we can achieve portable
scalability we can get close to these a
synchronized executions regardless of
the situations and we can do that
through a method that we propose that's
called asynchronous concurrency and I'm
going to go into more details regarding
this now but the fundamental idea is
that you should try to design your
concurrent data structures such that the
memory access patterns are as similar as
possible to the sequential counterparts
because those really represent the upper
bound there so this would suggest that
there are some algorithms they're
already very close to even an incorrect
execution yeah why do we have to do
warrior well for example it might not be
the same algorithm that's close here and
that's close here so we what would like
an algorithm that's very close to that
regardless of the situation so
regardless of the platter
yes robustness and portability as well
good
so here maybe this algorithm performs
very well in that scenario and this is
not the case of these Vista here so
you're stating that the best algorithm
here is not the best algorithm there yes
actually we did notice that it varies
quite a lot reaching platforms so I'm
very good understand a little bit why
mr. book this is not probably an upper
bound right so you can structure your
genus reference as weighted would you go
better than this do your partitioning
say in a way with some of the problem
maybe you see here just taking a single
core data structure in scale yes
many ways of getting to do something
special that's a bike could that be
better than this so I think not if you
want to maintain a consistent single
data structure as your main abstraction
I think these a synchronized executions
to provide the minimum number of stores
because really all they change is the
semantically necessary data so if I'm
using a treat it all they're doing is
really just inserting the new node in
that tree if you're using a hash table
for example again that you can see it as
partition in a sense but then you also
need to somehow communicate between the
different partitions at a point I think
that's maybe it's not about your
database you can think of hack it will
keep it private you send a message I was
actually updating you know how maybe go
get it right will that be with that if
you implement it does video search it
will be so yeah we've looked into that
as well so for these kind of data
structures search data structures that's
not the case and that's because you
don't really have a lot of contention
really the scalability is just limited
by cache line transfers which you would
have when you're using message passing
as well now if you're using a data
structure that has that inherently has
some points of contention such as Q for
example or a stack there we found that
it might be useful to use such an
approach yes but not for search data
structures we found that this is always
much much better
my total true to the voice all sharing
could improve on here
the quadrant one right because because
if the limited concurrency is just cache
line moves it may be that you're getting
cache line moves in our action necessary
for communication move and you seem to
be better than here we have really tried
to optimize that so even for the
sequential ones we have tried to put a
single key value pair on a single cache
line for example and not have it shared
yeah there's not one differential
implementation even for the professional
presentation at multiple one we have a
parameter so you would also have to show
multiple lines or the sequential version
um surely you can influence some data
structures in different ways you can so
here I am showing the ones that where we
did the optimizations that prevented
unnecessary cache traffic because that
was fundamentally what causes
scalability problems so we did take care
for example to not place multiple
unrelated note on the same cache lines
yeah
but the algorithms themselves I would
say it doesn't cause too much of a
difference because I mean in a tree when
you're doing the removal for example you
still need to change two nodes right and
that's a fit right if you're going to
take a class and then you fill up
routers for the cache you know data
layout potentially yeah yeah yeah it's
actually the data layer that's important
here okay so this is actually what I
wanted to talk about here so why are
these good upper bounds well because of
the way the hardware works so as I said
the more stores you have on shared data
the more cache traffic you have the more
cache traffic you have more often you
will find that the data that you want
access is not in a valid state and you
will have to bring it from some remote
core so the higher your memory access
latencies will become so the lower your
scalability will become and really DC
question implementations really have
just that stores necessary to do the
semantic updates to the data structure
just to modify the nodes the data in the
notes that you want modified so that's
why they're a reasonable upper bound
there is some so if someone has for
example inserted someone on let's say
one processor has inserted node a and I
now want to remove note a I do have to
bring the data from process the first
processor to my processor where I'm
going to remove but really that's
unavoidable there needs to be some
communication between those two notes
but still operating on shared a yeah
yeah that might result in some incorrect
no so there are a few updates that are
lost because of this but they are they
do provide a good upper bound
nonetheless okay so what is actually a
synchronize concurrency in practice so
it's actually a set of four patterns we
call them the ASCII patterns and before
I go into details into how they operate
I need to briefly talk about how the
state-of-the-art concurrent algorithms
for these data structures operate so as
I said we have a simple interface insert
remove and search now search methods
really just need to go through the data
structure to reach the point of interest
and check if the data is there so they
just have one phase now inserts and
removes for which I will use the
umbrella term updates because they
operate in a very similar fashion they
first need to parse the data structures
who get to the point of interest then
they need to perform some sort of
validation in a sequential algorithm if
you want to remove one out this
validation is just
if the data is there or not but in a
concurrent algorithm of course this
validation phase needs to be concurrency
aware so you need to make sure that the
state on which you're operating is
correct and then you actually have a
modify phase where the semantics updates
to the data structures are performed and
we have four patterns for each of these
four phases so one for the search
operation and one for each of the phases
of update operations and I'm going to
talk about each of these patterns in
turn so first
the pattern that deals with search
operations so if you look at a
sequential algorithm the search
operation is read only just traverse the
data structure and if the node that
you're searching for is there you return
if not to return failure and we claim
that you can do this in concurrent
algorithms as well so you can avoid
having any stores any waiting or any
retries in a search method so really it
can be more or less identical to the
sequential implementation and fornix for
example we looked at a linked list and
it's actually one of the link list that
has the best scalability of all its Tim
Harris is limitless maybe you're
familiar with it so what it was doing in
the search method it was trying to do
some cleanup of logically deleted nodes
so during the delete method you first
logically mark your mark a node that's
being logically deleted and at some
point in the future you unlink it from
the data structure however we claim that
this is not the place to do that you can
leave that for updates and read
operations you should maintain the
semantics of the operation itself so you
can do this in a read-only manner so you
can traverse the data structure even
progress these logical related mark
nodes and still have a correct
implementation and to show you how this
influences scalability so here I'm using
a workload with a linked list of 1024
elements 5% updates I am showing the
throughput as a function of the number
of cores in red I have the synchronized
execution in green the original
algorithm and in black
the updated algorithm just by applying
this pattern so not applying other
patterns and we do observe that we do
get up to 30% higher throughput for some
numbers of course just by applying this
pattern okay
and I should know that I'm only showing
one example Forex pattern but we were
able to apply them to multiple published
algorithms actually okay the second
pattern deals with the parses of update
operations so in a sequential algorithm
again if we look we just have a
traversal of the elements no stores no
no retry is no waiting here in a
concurrent implementation we do allow
some cleaning up but we claim that you
can do this even without doing any
waiting or any retries in this face so
for example we looked at the Skip list
algorithm which was doing some cleanup
of logically marked nodes but it was it
would restart if any of these clean
clean gap operations would fail and we
saw that this is not truly necessary
during this bar space it's only
necessary if the cleanup concerns one of
the nodes on which you want it to do an
update so we say that if your atomic
operation fails you can just continue
operation in this phase it will not have
any impact on correctness and we're
actually able to show that so we have
the TD algorithm such that it never has
to restart in this phase and now I'm
showing a workout I first skip lists
using 1024 elements 20% updates so
really just 20% of the operations shown
here are concerned by by this pattern
and we observe up to 8% higher
throughput and this worked up just by
applying this what does 20% of this
really being died doing that in this
skip list yeah a random set of elements
is going to be modified on or is there
some structure to these updates now
there's no structure so really or we
start with 1024 elements skip list our
ski keys
is twice that such that
probabilistically we maintain the size
of the data structure giving run time
and then we draw a number at random if
it's here smaller than 22 and updates
within that update
Rizzoli's how to run this multiple times
and in Kiev sort of various and
cartridges all right yeah yeah is this
what you're doing here or is this just
one execution not an outreach our course
no no we're I think this is the median
of five executions if I remember
correctly
and it is following up on the question
is Q in the keys or I interview that
soon you might citizens the content is
best kids
the gate was integrate 10 personally how
much this is us as it's very visible yes
a group again so it is q builder
improvement alright so in this we
actually didn't see a big difference in
how much this improves based on the skew
of the workload if you really have just
some popular keys the scalability of all
of these will decrease to some extent
but these these patterns still remained
unofficial okay the third pattern deals
with unsuccessful update operations
deals with the validation phase so in a
sequential implantation again if we look
what you would do if for example you
want to remove a key that simply not
there you just return false and what we
call what we want to do through our
third pattern is to avoid any stores as
much as possible if your update would be
unsuccessful so for example we looked at
a hash table and what they were doing
was getting to the point in the bucket
where they wanted to do the update
locking then checking if the steak with
in that bucket actually allows them to
perform the update and if not just on
our can fail and what we claim that in
these situations are much better pattern
for these concurrent applications is to
instead check then lock and then check
again so it is possible that even though
you lock so you do a store you might
still fail but it's extremely unlikely
in most of the cases for unsuccessful
updates you will not do any stores you
will not lock anything so essentially
we're trying to maintain the semantics
that we have in sequential data
structures so what's read on the
operation maintain it as read on each
year as well
and here I'm using a hash table with one
with eight thousand eleven five thousand
buckets 10 percent updates and I'm
showing here the latency instead of the
throughput
foreign successful updates
to make the to show the benefits of this
have been more clear and what we can see
is that here really since we're using a
hash table the buckets are pretty small
the latency of unsuccessful operations
was dominated by those lakh acquisitions
and we're able to actually decrease the
latency of operation by a factor of four
by applying this pattern yep
sometimes you're Valerie yes so this is
because sometimes there is some
incorrectness in the a synchronized
execution so sometimes you do end up
with a larger data structure in the
synchronized executions because while
some removes may be then actually occur
and this especially happens for when
your data structure is confined to a
single socket because the completa the
latencies are smaller so the updates to
the data structure some probably more
frequent that's what's happening here
yeah and finally our fourth pattern
deals with the actual modify phase so
the phase where you actually need to
modify your data structure so in a
sequential algorithm you have the
minimum number of possible stores you
really do just the stores necessary to
modify the data and we would like to
have that and concurrent algorithms as
well and for example we looked at log
based binary search trees and the best
algorithm we could find was taking
actually up to four logs per update and
we said that it's worth having the
algorithm maybe Traverse a few more
pointers in read mode and to be able to
save some of those slack operations in
terms of performance so we design an
algorithm that yes compared to what was
previously available does Traverse a bit
more pointers but it only needs two
lakhs per update so we keep the memory
access patterns in terms of stores as
close as possible to the sequential
algorithm and sure I'm using the binary
search tree with 2048 elements 20%
updates and I'm showing how the update
latency varies as a function of number
of cores oh and by the way this jump
point here that represents a socket
boundary so it's where
go from one processor to to the next
so anyway by applying this pattern to
this binary search you we were able to
obtain up to 30% lower latency for this
operation so to conclude on this work
I'm in all of these experiments I've
shown just how one pattern is applied in
isolation we were actually able to apply
multiple of these patterns to quite a
lot of already published algorithms and
yep your veterans applies like that's
free you just observe this is comparable
yeah yeah yeah so I would say maybe 50%
of the algorithms that we consider were
a lot based and 50% for lottery and yeah
you can apply them to both I think I
fully understand the exact it was
pattern me so further than it's not an
automatic transformation we don't start
it in French now treatment automatically
produces this version that is you know
so it's essentially a number so these
four patterns represent a set of
sufficient conditions for your data
structure to be scalable so yes I don't
think you could use them to
automatically generate the data
structure algorithm where you have so
somebody who has some experiences of
free data structure looks at the
algorithm and determined how your pilot
pattern yes or if you're just starting
your system now when you're trying to
build your algorithm constructed from
scratch you do have a set of sufficient
conditions that your algorithm needs to
fulfill so you do have funny alright so
the defense Rogerson doesn't have long
so where does this idea come from like
very first a lot okay so of course all
of these algorithms actually have per
node locks so lock at very fine-grain
granularity now in terms of exactly
which nodes you lock what we were saying
is that you should if you look at that
sequential algorithm you see on which
notes there are stores
you should ideally lock only those nodes
in a concurrent algorithm as well
much as possible great so long so that's
one thing I was getting to actually did
allow us to come up with a couple of new
algorithms one was that tree I was
mentioning so we were for example by
knowing that if you only lock the if you
manage to only lock the nodes to which
you semantically need to do
modifications you improve scalability we
were able to for example come up with
that modified binary search tree
algorithm that just does that so it does
make the task somewhat simpler of course
it doesn't make it trivial I'm not
claiming that could concurrent data
structures are still a difficult
discipline but I think it does simplify
this task a bit okay so an artifact of
this work was actually a skill II which
is a library that at this point contain
somewhere between 40 and 45
implementation of limitations of
state-of-the-art algorithms and it's
been used quite widely especially in
academia so now that we've actually been
discussing about lock-free and log based
algorithms one of the interesting things
we noticed here is that as long as you
you know apply this pattern there is no
intrinsic difference in terms of
scalability and performance between log
base 10 log three algorithms however we
did notice that log based algorithms do
tend to be simpler to think about and to
design that log three algorithms so
actually one question that I was curious
to answer was well are blocking
concurrent search data structures
actually the optimal choice or do we
need to go with lock tree algorithms and
before I can answer that I need to talk
a bit about progress guarantee so the
progress guarantee is the theoretical
progress guarantees that another them
provide tells you what you can expect
from the behavior of individual threads
now most published algorithms are either
blocking that generally means they use
locks
for these data structures they mostly
provide dialogue freedom at least and
then there are non blocking algorithms
in practice lock free ones are the most
common but in terms of progress
guarantee strength weight free
algorithms are the strongest and what a
weight free algorithm guarantees is that
every thread that it's trying to take
steps will complete its operation
eventually regardless of what everyone
else in the system is doing so this is
what you would ideally like to have in
an algorithm from a practical
perspective we say that an
implementation whose behavior is
indistinguishable from that of a
theoretically weight free algorithm is
practically weight free and now going
back to my question so how does the
ideal concurrent data structure look
like so first of all it's easy to design
implement and reason about and blocking
algorithms to tend to be simpler than
the others both in terms of how you
program it and how you use it from a
memory management perspective and so on
it does provide good to prevent
scalability and we've observed in our
previous work that docking algorithms do
provide that but if you want to provide
some sort of SLA maybe you would also
like your data structure to not have the
majority of of its requests delay due to
concurrency so really you want to
minimize the number of requests that are
significantly related to concurrency so
you want to be behaved practically like
a tree algorithm so that's something
that's not yet clear if it's true for
blocking algorithms intuitively it
shouldn't be now of course it's
something that's true for theoretically
weight free algorithms and previous work
has shown that this is probabilistically
true for a lock free and obstruction
free algorithms as well but I wanted to
see if for these class of data
structures so for search data structures
where there's no real inherent point of
contention this can be true as well
obviously there's no way of proving this
theoretically if you're using locks you
cannot show that something is weight
free so I took the approach one
empirical study here I looked at a very
large spectrum of locking data
structures the one in our previously
mentioned library and I really tried to
run them on a very large spectrum of
workloads different thread counts
different update ratio
introduced all sorts of delays and
non-uniformities and so on and the
question that I really wanted to answer
was is there at least one algorithm for
each data structure type that behaves in
a practically weight free manner in all
of these scenarios so what does it
really mean in practice for an algorithm
to behave practically weight free so I
said that an algorithm is practically
weight free as long as the vast majority
of its requests are not delayed severely
due to concurrency now if you just look
at for example the latencies of
individual requests that won't be enough
because you might have all sorts of
interrupts context switches and so on
so individual agencies might be very
large regardless of the progress
guarantee of your algorithm but by
looking at the state-of-the-art
algorithms there if they're blocking
algorithms there are actually two delays
due to concurrency in such algorithms
one is weak of course because of waiting
for locks so I am waiting for some other
thread to release its locks in order to
be able to make progress and the second
is because requests might have to be
restarted due to inconsistent State
remember that part that I mentioned
earlier where you need to check even
after you lock the fact that the state
that you're currently accessing is
actually consistent so from our
practical standpoint if you have a very
low percentage of time spent waiting for
locks in a very low percentage of time a
very low percentage of requests that are
restarted you have practically weight
free behavior now I'm just going to
briefly show a typical scenario here and
we'll go into a lot of details so I'm
using the Skip list twenty thread 2048
elements and I'm showing the values of
these two metrics for different updates
per update percentages and we have
values way below 1% in all these cases
and if we look at the tail as well
there's no request that was waiting for
more than seven microseconds and all
requests that was waiting for more that
was we started for more than three times
so we do have practically wait for
behavior now this was the case for
almost all of our workloads I'm not
going to show results for all of them
there was just one problem attic
scenario one fully programmatic scenario
where a practical weight freedom broke
and that's when you have
very common thread preemption when your
system is significantly oversubscribed
so you have very frequent contact
switches now these state-of-the-art
algorithms as I said use very
fine-grained locking and they really
only lock when necessary but even though
that's the case if you have very
frequent thread preemption you're bound
to be the schedule from time to time
when you're holding a lock and since a
thread can be switched out for
milliseconds
there's bound to be some queuing behind
that thread and if that happens now the
solution we propose here is to use HTM
and the lock algorithms so HTM Hardware
transaction memory essentially allows
you to execute critical sections in a
speculative way without acquiring the
lock so you don't acquire the lock you
execute your critical section and then
the hardware detective there is any
conflict if anyone else outside of your
transaction has read or written the data
that that you're concerned with current
implementations our best opportunity so
there are besides these data conflicts
there are a bunch of reasons why
transaction can be aborted including
contact switches so if you were to have
a correct implementation you should try
to execute a critical section maybe two
or three times like this using a
speculative execution after which you
should actually fall back on acquiring
the lock it's the only way to to
guarantee that your algorithm is not
starvation free so that's what waited
did in our data structures we kept the
algorithms so it's no extra effort from
the implementers point of view we just
change the locking algorithms to use HTM
and we took advantage of the feature
that I previously mentioned a
transaction is aborted when you have a
contact switch this is generally
regarded as an inconvenience but it
actually works in our favor here here
for example I'm showing what happens
when you're using 8 threads per physical
core and I'm measuring the percentage of
critical sections that fall back on
actually acquiring the lock for most of
the data structures this is well below
1% for skip list since they acquire a
logarithmic number of slugs per update
this number is somewhat larger
what so it was an inter machine with
yeah for course it's the one we had with
HTML money all it takes pretty obvious
of preemption right uh right um so here
I did look at this and if I remember a
thread was contact switched out for a
couple of milliseconds so it was
switched out and then we scheduled after
a couple of milliseconds so I guess the
quantum was a couple little seconds
which means it
yeah several hundreds of microseconds
that seems incredibly fast but it
probably seems really okay sorry if I
remember the measurements that I did
correctly that was it but this
particular the fridge is a bigger than
quantum is the less often things are bad
well actually for this I'm not sure that
has that much of an impact because here
so what I'm measuring here is just the
percentage of critical sections that
fall back to acquiring blocks
so I'm trying a critical section three
or four times in speculative mode so it
basically never happens at 4-4 thread to
busy schedules yeah yeah
okay so we actually managed to avoid the
vast majority of Loch acquisitions here
and we also looked at how beneficial
deserves for performance in this case
and we generally obtain the speed-up of
2/3 X by using this because you
basically avoid being contacts reached
out while holding a lock in the vast
majority of cases for skips this was
particularly impressive and this is
because as I said skip this do tend to
acquire quite a lot of locks so it would
happen quite often that a thread that
was not scheduled was holding a lock but
we obtained speed ups of more than 10x
here so we do manage to maintain
practically weight free behavior here as
well so conclusion here would be that
every system is disliked vigorously
context pre-empting threads that you're
much more likely to be holding a lot
where the thread is preempted because it
granted not my problem right yeah but
it's also less detrimental to
performance right fe you get less jitter
I'm prodigy so operating systems are
firing timers 100 microsecond is that
really true pretty fast yeah
so if I recall the measurements that I
did at the time it was around that this
number girls but there used to be tens
of milliseconds they have this not look
at another chip with the kardashians you
have to keep asleep on generator it was
used to solve rotor dynamics and ask
who's in the histogram
so actually you can do after surprise
but just running on the next or this run
yeah I would have to double check my
numbers here just to be a hundred
percent sure but if I remember correctly
this was a couple of years ago it was
along this scale okay so a couple of
words of caution here so we're not
saying that every blocking concurrent
search data structure algorithm is
practically wait for you we're saying
that the really the state-of-the-art
ones do behave in a practically weight
free manner and we're not saying that
every data structure has such an
algorithm for example stacks and queues
we flip to them as well and this
conclusion does not apply to them this
applies to search data structures but if
you want a scalable system
you shouldn't have probably have a stack
or a queue at its core in any case but
as I said this does apply to the
state-of-the-art algorithm so if you're
a system developer and you have some
idea about the workloads that your
system is going to run on and really the
hard guarantees that you need to provide
to the user in many situations you're
safe
going with a blocking algorithm because
they're fast they're scalable and
they're much easier to design and
implement and work with sure all the
faces they know exactly what running on
it how possible is it to get rid of
how much completely like now that we're
subscribing you know using only as many
Prentice and I go yeah yeah yeah if you
have complete control of your system yes
this is not an issue you know
complicated a tree a tree
yeah I would say there is no reason in
that case where to set of structures but
obviously it's not very common the case
that you control everything
the Reds do have is relson insertions
right yeah but those are so they're I
would say they're infrequent enough for
this not to be an issue so we've tried
for example what happens with 2x thread
oversubscription so when you have two
threads per core upper hardware context
and it wasn't really an issue it starts
becoming an issue one context switches
are really start to be pretty frequent
so I would say occasional exceptions
that interrupts are acceptable perfectly
wait free you show some numbers I know
it only takes seven microseconds to get
through something to go through the
personalization yes to access the deck
structure but if it were 10 will it
still be 12 15 will they still be
practically made for you with the
boundary I wish you say oh there's no
good anymore
yeah so it's difficult to come up with a
really hard boundary that's why I was
saying like if you have some idea about
the hard constraints that your system
needs to provide to the user using that
information you can say whether or not
this is practically weight free but I
would say so seven microseconds for the
slowest request in that execution is a
very acceptable number you could put it
at the nose I think you could say I won
99% of my requests not have a latency
larger than one millisecond for example
but that is something that you as a user
need to specify okay so we started with
this wish list for concurrent data
structures we wanted them to be fast
scalable and easy to reason about and
we've more or less covered all of these
points so we're done right well as I
said software systems really need to be
aware of new technologies and to be
adapted to them as hardware changes
software needs to change as well and we
can expect non-volatile Ram to become
ubiquitous in the next couple of years
so now we can add persistence to that
wish list for data structures so how can
we ensure performance and persistence at
the same time because we don't want to
lose a lot of that performance and
scalability of data structures when
using non-volatile Ram so a bit about
non-volatile Ram so non-volatile Ram
promises persistent data at latencies
that are comparable to DRAM somewhat
larger depending on which technology
will become prevalent latencies of
stores are expected to be somewhat
larger than latest latencies of loads
and from a programming model perspective
you're expected to be able to map
non-volatile Ram to a region of virtual
memory and then work with it as you
would with the RAM and the main
challenge here is to have performance
but at the same time have consistency
after a restart so if you're executing
your application your machine crashes
and you need to restart it the state
that you have in your persistent RAM
needs to be able to allow you to
continue execution from where you work
and that's actually not trivial at all
so let's start from a simple example
let's say that I want to allocate some
data initialize it with content link it
in a couple of places in some data
structure and then just say that I'm
done with my operation normally this is
pretty simple I would just have to be
careful for these stores to appear in my
write back cache in the order in which I
want them to and to be able to do that I
just need to be aware of the memory
consistency model of my processor as
long as I know that I can control the
the order in which stores appear in my
right back cache but by default I don't
control the order in which cache lines
are evicted and written back to memory
so in this example I might have a
scenario where the cache line that's
linking my newly allocating memory is
affected and written to persistent RAM
the cache line that has my flag saying
that I'm done is persisted and then I
have a crash and upon restart I have a
pointer to some uninitialized memory so
I need to fix this and I can do that by
ensuring that my stores are persisted in
to a non-volatile Ram in the order in
which I assure them in my program now
how can you do that I'm going to take a
few seconds to talk about that so an
upcoming inter processors at least you
will have a cache line right back
instruction and that what that allows
you to do is to as the name says write
back a care sign to memory from the
cache without invalidating it and these
instructions are not ordered with
respect to one another so you can
actually issue multiple of them and they
will mostly occur in parallel they're
not ordered with respects to stores
either if you want an ordering point you
need to use a store fence there so the
point here is that if you can batch
these write backs you will have overall
better performance ok so now back to our
example now we know how we can persist
these stores but we're still not done
we're still not out of the woods so even
though we persist the stores in program
order
there might still be a crash in the
middle of our operation and the pond
restarts we don't know have we completed
our transaction is this a consistent
stage we have to go back and undo
everything so to be safe in general we
need to log everything so you don't need
to pay attention to every logging
instruction there the point that I was
going to make is that you start from a
very simple operation and you end up
with something very complicated where
you have very frequent waiting for data
to be written to persistent memory and
then especially for logging you need to
ensure that those operations are
completed before you you proceed because
you need to ensure that the log is
written before the operation that
actually depends
and it executes and this is really bad
if you're starting from a program that
used to run in volatile memory generally
when you were doing this tour that will
go to your l1 cache your operation would
take a handful of cycles now because you
have to frequently write to persistent
memory and wait for that to complete
your operations take hundreds of cycles
is that so you really lose a lot of
performance and in particular logging is
problematic for the reasons that I
mentioned previously and so I looked at
concurrent data structures and how you
can remove most of these overheads in
the context of persistent memory and we
used a number of different principles
and solutions here for the data
structure while previously argued for
using log base data structures here I
argue for using lot free data structures
so log freedom says that no matter what
is happening in your system at least one
thread that is trying to make progress
is able to make progress one of the
consequences of this is that no thread
at any point in its execution should
leave the system in a state from which
someone else cannot continue execution
so the state of your system should never
be invalid and actually that allows us
to save a lot of logging if you're using
a log based algorithms where you have
some critical sections you need to log
what's happening in those critical
sections because if you crash in the
middle of a critical section you might
be in some inconsistent state with
lovely algorithms
since you're modifying your data
structures through atomic steps you are
never in an inconsistent state so you
save some logging for that then another
aspect that requires very frequent
logging is memory allocation and
reclamation normally in order to avoid
persistent memory leaks which are really
bad because well a persistent memory
leak is there forever until you somehow
manage to find it you generally need to
log allocations at every allocation and
de-allocation so what we propose instead
is to just track active memory areas for
each thread and then do some extra work
at recovery and this is a general
principle that we've used in in a number
of ways here too
avoid overhead at runtime while maybe
doing a bit more work at recovery to
bring your system in a consistent state
and where possible we also try to batch
right backs so instead of doing them one
at a time and waiting for them to be
completed do them all together and yep
these transactions yeah so you can if
how about you choose the culture go back
there to your batch equated it
yeah but yeah but you still so if you
stance actions you still fundamentally
have that copy-on-write logging you
still have logging right with lock-free
algorithms for this you can completely
avoid log that kind of logging so that's
why we're advocating for for this don't
ever leave the data structure
inconsistency how they typically have an
assumption that that once they've done
something is persistent which is
violated by disorder cache line right
bags across the crash right if you have
an extra problem here I mean you guys
said great we have a three of these walk
free you know these lockrey algorithms
want three algorithms have this
beautiful property that everything is
consistent all the time yeah that is
certainly the case for a lot free
algorithms running in a concurrent
execution environment yeah right but if
a lot free algorithm does two things
first one than the other of the
consistency assumption the consistency
property may depend on the first one
having happen which is not necessarily
true in a system but this already after
effects and crashes right so don't you
need an extra property here yes
so I will talk about that obviously you
need some ordering between the updates
that the log fire is in here somewhere
right
yes Lee yeah okay
yeah I mean goes right back to our
country instructions yeah
all right no yeah but do not go round
right because you get in a concurrent
education the cash consistency mechanism
will make sure they have spread a is
written if Freddie does write one right
- and a trendy C's right - will also see
right want though it's not necessarily
true I'd be writing that like doggies go
tell it right because it is sometimes
the problem there beckoning non-cash
method they don't have it really did and
it got very similar to in our customers
well yeah it's the instruction that I
was talking about so if you issue a cash
and right back instruction for a
particular address and then you issue a
store funds after that you're sure that
that update has been persisted right now
in current machine G I believe that so
it's like perfect little incoherence in
your cash and not with they're not going
to make memories
so this is what Intel claims for the
upcoming processes it's something
they're introduced so right now we're
really sorry I really yes find that very
hard to believe
so make it a little nice assortment you
know you're not where memory fast okay
so it goes through all right
that's the difference thank you and
actually right now in current machines
you do have a CL flush instruction cache
I'm flush which that's the same but one
it invalidates the caching from your
write back cache which you generally
don't really want and these are ordered
with respect to one another so you
cannot take advantage of batching when
did you know that yeah for gosh
thank memories anniversary fans yes okay
so I'm going to use a skip list as a
running example here so if you take a
lottery algorithm and after every store
that you do you issue a right back can
you wait for it to complete you do have
a correct algorithm but you we would
like to do better than that so the first
thing we notice for example in a skip
list I'm using this because it's a
pretty complex data structure so if for
those of you who don't know skip this is
actually a multi-layer link list that
allows you to have logarithmic time
search so normally when you insert a
node you need to allocate it and then
start linking it in the Skip list one
level at a time however for example for
this data structure we notice that the
higher layers are only there for routing
efficiency the bottom layer is the one
that actually determines membership so
you only need to ensure the fact that
the bot the link in the bottom layer is
present there exactly what you need it
to be for the higher layers we can just
proceed without waiting for those links
to be persisted and then upon recovery
we can actually do a bit of work and
bring the data structure back into a
consistent State so really you need to
persist only the essential links here
and in fact for this we can actually go
even further and avoid persisting even
the bottom layer link their level link
there so normally what you would have to
do for this bottom the special bottom
layer link is what once you allocate and
initialize the node when you insert a
link to it you need to insert a link
that's marked as not yet persisted
because you want to avoid the following
scenario you insert a link to that node
it's not yet persisted because it takes
a bit there's a concurrent read
operation sees that newly inserted node
return series of the fact that the node
is present in the set there's a crash
and upon restart that notes not log is
there because there was no time for the
link to be persisted so the method that
we use is we first insert a marked link
the thread that does the insertion also
tries to persist this but if there's
another operation that directly depends
on that link that operation will also
try to persist before
persisting it before returning the
result however we claim that this is not
really necessary because a link only
really needs to be persisted when there
is an operation that directly depends on
its presence or absence in the data
structure so what we propose the
following we use a very fast concurrent
in volatile memory cache that stores
links in the bottom layer that have not
yet been persisted and then when enough
when another operation occurs it tests
whether there are any links pertaining
to the key value pair of interest in
that fast in volatile memory buffer and
if that's the case it is right back in a
batch for all the links in that buffer
so it's actually you are able to take
advantage of batching and you're able to
persist multiple links at the same time
instead of waiting for each of them to
be persisted so this is how we avoid
waiting for write backs at runtime yep
in what sense is it the so yes if you
want to provide inner eyes ability you
can only acknowledge that an update has
been completed when that link is flushed
oh yes yeah yeah but yes even a
Drivetime if you do want in irritability
you can only consider a store an update
and insert to remove as being linearized
when everything has been persistent then
this is our capacity yes sense that
you're always working on the same global
version of the rate structure or while
you're going through your topic the
version of the dates of the code change
no no so this provides a paucity I think
I would argue is that you can only give
way north ability to rape and kill these
cases but if you feel sure that nobody
can read the potato memory in any other
way
then you go for all people who are
connected to the experiences which they
get their experiences on well so for
example if you're using this in a
distributed system someone wants to do
an update you issue the update you can
only send an acknowledgement to the user
that it's update has been completed when
everything pertaining to that updates
has been persisted right for a different
reason this it sort of like the end of
the message signifies position and
appendage Chris decided different some
later and clearly as a concurrency
control you know kind of thing yes with
now it's been said I will never go back
on the fact that you have committed
okay I guess yeah if you can't the
recovery right yes and IP right yeah
okay okay so then we've also looked at a
problem of memory allocation and
reclamation so as I said you really want
to avoid any persistent memory leaks
here so normally what you'd have to do
is to log before each allocation you so
in general the steps are you allocating
something and then you link it in the
data structure
if crash occurs between these two you
might have a leak so you need to log
before this is very costly and we'd like
to avoid that so we make the following
observation so if you look at modern
memory alligators that are concurrently
aware the way that they work is that
they partition memory in larger chunks
that they hand out to individual threads
and then individual threads cut this
into smaller chunks and give them to the
application so if you're doing a number
of allocations on a single on a
particular thread for example
consecutive allocations are likely to
allocate from pretty similar memory
areas similarly with memory reclamation
you cannot indeed there are structures
you cannot free an out immediately after
it's unlink you need to wait to make
sure that no one has any references to
it anymore
and in order for this to be efficient
what people doing practice is they
gather a pretty large number of nodes
and they periodically check which of
these are for sure not reachable and no
one has pointers ISM to them anymore and
then they are freed altogether so when
you're reclaiming memory you're
reclaiming good on the order of hundreds
of nodes at a time and what we notice is
that out of these hundreds of nodes
several of them do tend to map to the
same memory areas again so essentially
what I'm trying to say here is that
there is locality in a memory allocation
and reclamation so we take advantage of
this by instead of logging each
allocation or the allocation just log
the active memory areas for each thread
and based on some metadata associated
with memory
Meishan system we can actually keep
these this active memory area set quite
up-to-date and pretty small and then
again we use the same principle of doing
some extra work at recovery so at
recovery time we go over the memory
areas that were active at the mana
moment of the crash we see which of the
nodes stored in those memory areas are
reachable in the data structure we keep
those as allocated those that are not
reachable anymore we free so this is
very much the working progress I'll just
give some preliminary results here we
don't have non-volatile Ram for now
we're just using some simulation based
on some published numbers it's what
Intel's open-source libraries doing for
now as well so here I'm showing the
update latency as a fraction of a nun
optimized lock-free algorithm so I'm
already comparing with a log free
algorithm here we would do much better
if I would compare with a log based
algorithm but that's upcoming work so we
notice that for small and medium sized
data structures we decrease the latency
by a factor of about two as the data
structure size increases our benefits
become less impressive and that's
because the latency of an update becomes
dominated just by the time necessary to
reach the point in the data structure
where you want to do to do the update in
terms of recovery time we do pretty well
for now so for one a one gigabyte
scriptures we do about 6 milliseconds
which upon a reboot is reasonable but
we're working on optimizing this even
further we think we can do better here
so I'll conclude on this so we've
managed to come up with a number of
principles that when used result in fast
persistent concurrent data structures in
particular you should use lock tree
algorithms you need to be careful when
you issue write backs you only need to
issue rad backs and wait for them to
complete for really critical update you
should try to defer work for recovery as
much as you can and buffer right back
together whenever possible ok so this
concludes what I wanted to say about
concurrent data structures I just want
to very quickly go over some other
because I've been looking into another
problems that I think are interesting
one was our study of synchronization
where we wanted to see what is it
exactly that enables a concurrent object
to scale in practice so we want to see
how much is it the nature of the object
and how much does the precise algorithm
that it's using impact performance how
much does the hardware impact
performance this is an interesting bug
so we did a thorough study along two
axis we looked at a very large spectrum
of software implementations for software
or for locking for message-passing then
for high layer systems such as hash
tables in memory caches and so on and we
also looked at the hardware we looked at
atomic operations and we looked at the
characteristics of the cache coherence
as well and we tried this along the very
varied set of platforms and while we
were able to come up with the number of
interesting conclusions the main point
here was that the behavior
synchronization is really a property of
the underlying hardware an outcome of
this work worse but also these two
libraries one is a locking library what
the other one is a cache coherence
benchmarking library which are used
quite widely on academia but also in
industry actually I've also looked at
message passing agreement in
multi-course so so far people have
generally looked at the multi-core as a
shared memory system however there has
been work that showed that there are
scalability and portability issues for
example battle fish yeah Andrews not
here so the alternative that was
proposed was to look at the multi-core
as a distributed system and here
communication is done only to explicit
message passing but in such a system you
need two port abstractions from
distributed system to this new
environment because the characteristics
of the system are pretty different and
we looked at one such important
abstraction and that's agreement before
our work there used to be only blocking
protocols that were explored we proposed
a modified version of Paxos that
actually perform pretty well in this
environment both in terms of scalability
and throughput and latency then more
recently I've been looking at
concurrency country
of researchers from VMware so most known
protocols today whether it's two-phase
locking on multi-version concurrency
control they lock either entire objects
or at least versions of objects but as
I've seen the finer grained locking the
finer grained a lot finer great locking
is extremely beneficial for scalability
in general for concurrent data
structures we can apply this to
concurrency control as well so we asked
what if instead of locking objects on
entire versions of our objects you lock
individual points of logical time and
that allows you to come up with an
entire new family of concurrency control
protocols for now we've just set up the
theoretical foundations of this so we've
done the theoretical work behind this
and we were able to show that for
example we can come up with an algorithm
that theoretically commits strictly more
work loads than multi-version
concurrency control for example but we
can also come up with algorithms and
solve some other issues present in
existing protocols and there's of course
a lot of work to be done here and I'll
conclude by briefly discussing some
future areas of interest so doing my PhD
I've mostly focused on multi-core
systems but I would like to work on
larger scale systems in the future
especially as you know the boundaries of
individual machines become somewhat
Burgh in particular I think the as you
know non-volatile random persistent
memory fast persistent memory in general
becomes more available I think that will
change how we design for example rack
scale system you can't think of a ver
axial system where you have a single
address space of non-volatile Ram for
example and it would be interesting to
see how exactly should build such a
system how do you deal with failures and
restarts and consistency and so on I do
think there's a lot more work to be done
up in software for heterogeneous
platforms so I've looked at concurrency
so far for you know the machines that we
have today which are very much cache
coherence the big course in our machines
all have access to cache coherence and
so on but in the future as Moore's Law
will
slow down in the next 69 years it's
expected to stop we will likely have way
more heterogeneous platforms we will be
able to extract more and more
performance by having specialized
hardware it's still not yet completely
clear how programming such system should
look at from a developer's perspective
because it should be relatively easy so
that's one problem I would like to look
at multi version times I'm locking the
concurrency control protocol that I've
mentioned previously I think there's
still more to be done there
we're in the process of implementing the
practical system based on this I would
like to look into some weight three data
structures I think there's more work to
be done there especially for stacks and
queues
I think there's we can still come up
with new algorithms and they're actually
wait for algorithms are beneficial and
I've seen that there are better than
they can do better than a lottery or a
log based one and then um as for example
energy efficiency becomes a really
important factor we've already seen some
approximate hardware appearing I think
we can do more work in approximate
algorithms as well especially for such
data structures so I would like to look
at into how you can design some work for
example concurrent data structures that
are approximate they still provide some
guarantees but they're not exact and
then I think that by looking at the
particularity zuv the networking side of
individual machines you can do more work
on message passing abstractions for an
individual machine and I will then share
a thing like it's almost up so thank you
so just a small question about this and
everything did you know sort of like if
you have a multi-core has its fancy
cache coherence and everything
you know that the best you could ever do
in terms of getting performance you know
agreement right like your memory is
creating the repeated actually not has
to write all that because hardware does
survive I would you look at at work so
it actually depends we've looked at
object implemented both through message
passing and through the scheduler here
in shared memory for the data structures
that I've talked about here it was
better to just use character here in
shared memory but for I don't know if
you have a counter for example or a
queue or a stack you can actually do
better by using I don't know delegating
the thread is responsible for that
object and having every other thread
just for example some messages to that
particular thread using message it seems
like you could have a lot of record
program for any special case right so
nobody will need is right to make all
these are progress that's what they do
well the problem is that you still have
a single point of contention in those
data structures so it's not that threads
are necessarily waiting for one another
for locks but the more threads tend to
access the same cache line thus Lord the
overall algorithm becomes so if you look
even at just lock algorithms themselves
it's why people have been using for
example cube locks well even for Lux
actually they have shown that there is
flat combining the method is right and
that uses message passing and it has
been shown when you have a lot of high
contention it does better than any kind
of lock yeah yes the question is really
like what didn't you say message passing
extractions what exactly means because
you can talk about you know reason right
to share memory I call these messages
yeah I mean if you don't have any other
best dedicated not success in hardware
that's how you will do message passing
but we have used for example a tiger a
processor that they'd have hardware
provided message passing and it was
pretty useful in it it did result in
very efficient compared object the
performance skill those you get is very
dependent on the hardware so out of all
this is that allows you to have a
conception of what the ideal hardware
would be for a custom design for some of
these algorithm so it I guess it depends
a bit on the object that you're trying
to implement but I guess the more
non-uniformity there is in your in your
hardware the more difficult it becomes
to to get something that's scalable for
example again talking about that Tyler a
processor it did have a lot of course
but it did have uniformity we looked at
another other kinds of processors that
had a comparable number comparable
number of course but a lot more non
uniformity and non uniformity does tend
to place a limit on on the overall
scalability
[Applause]